hi this is dr gregory sadler
i'm a professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason i o
where we put philosophy into practice
i've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years
and i find that many people run into
difficulties reading classic
philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
i come in
to help students and lifelong learners
i've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube
many viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos
each of them focused on one core concept
from an important philosophical text
i hope you find it useful as well
towards the end of the section absurd
freedom
in his work the myth of sisyphus albert
camus
is going to outline for us what we can
call an ethics of
quantity as opposed to one of
quality this is quite interesting
because it goes against
so many tendencies of
moral theory where we want to establish
you know distinctions in
quality and very often people want to
resist you know
a leveling putting everything on the
same sort of numerical uh level
plain point of view whatever you want to
say and then just accumulating things
the exception to that would of course be
you know utilitarian approaches
but even in the utilitarian movement we
see that eventually they have to
bring in distinctions between higher and
lower pleasures and therefore
distinctions of value i actually want to
begin
right in the middle of this section with
something that that camus
brings up he tells us that this this
notion of the most living calls for
definition and he says
it seems to begin with the fact that the
notion of quantity
has not been sufficiently explored
quantity right uh the amount of
something
and and what what is this going to be is
he is he really trying to just
level everything and say it doesn't
really matter what you do it's all
absurd anyway
so pick and choose any amount of
whatever you like and it's all just as
good
getting rid of any sort of value or
distinction altogether no
that's not what's going on there's
something a bit more subtle
happening here so a good place
to start in earnest then is to look at
what he's saying at the the very
beginning
of this and the contrast to we might
call it traditional
ways of doing ethics we do have to talk
about what we mean
by ethics or morality here as well
so he tells us that belief in the
meaning of life
always implies a scale of values a
choice
our preferences belief in the absurd
according to our definitions
teaches the contrary but this is worth
examining
before we go on to his examination let's
do a little examination of our own right
so belief in the meaning of life
involves having some sort of ethics or
morality and you might say well wait a
second not every
version of believing that there is some
sort of meaning to life
which might come along with believing in
human nature or the
you know some sort of metaphysics it
doesn't always have to imply an ethics
or a morality and you know show me some
that that don't and you'll find in
ethics
concealed in them quite frankly as soon
as you start
scratching the surface and engaging in
the sort of examination of of these
things genealogical examination that the
person who he brings up
the end of this chapter nietzsche did so
there's always
some sort of idea about
you know what's good and what's bad and
i should point out that
very often people think ethics is just a
matter
of ticking off boxes or compliance
or satisfying certain rules and and they
often want to try to reduce ethics to
something like a decision procedure
or algorithm and there is scope and
ethics for doing that and as a matter of
fact even the
ways of doing ethics that acknowledge
that there's more to that think that
that's important so a cost benefit
analysis
robert audi for example makes a great
case why even a conscience or virtue
ethicist would want to do cost-benefit
analysis and you might say an
existentialist
or absurdist might want to do that as
well as a tool
ethics from its inception
has been concerned with more than just
what are the rules that we need to live
by
it's oriented towards well what is
genuinely
valuable what's worth more than one else
prime example this would be say the
stoics claiming that
virtue is more important than everything
else that is
indifference but the indifference
themselves have values
we can come up with a scale or another
word that gets used
is a hierarchy of values another word
rank ordering right
so if we're an aristotelian we could say
well you know virtuous activity
is the best thing maybe contemplation if
we accept nickel mccain ethics book 10
above that and then we've got other
things like pleasure and health and
wealth and
those aren't bads those are actually
good things but they're not they're not
as important so we should prioritize
right a scale of values
involves making choices making decisions
sometimes right sometimes wrong
sometimes good sometimes bad
and we're not just thinking when we're
doing ethics about the immediate
situation
we might also be thinking about longer
term things like the nature of my whole
life or the fabric of my relationships
or the kind of person who i would like
to be
but am not yet quite but by doing the
right thing
i make myself better by choosing the
wrong thing i make myself
worse so so that's part of it as well
that again belief in
there being some sort of meaning of life
i should be a better person that's part
of the meaning of life
so choices decisions plays a role in
that preferences
is important as well and that often ties
in with the scale of values your
preferences
could be out of whack with the ideal
hierarchy or scale of values
rules play a role in it having rules to
get by
in our day-to-day existence rules to
settle difficult cases for ourselves
a rule of life as kamu is going to say
justification plays a role as well being
able to say to other
rational agents i'm not a complete
screw-up take a look at
my motivations here and you know the
actions that i did
or i am a real screw-up and i really
need to fix things
right lack of justification and then he
also a little bit earlier in the chapter
talked about before the
absurd the ordinary person has all sorts
of goals and aims and ends
they're oriented towards a future the
absurd
takes that future away makes it
uncertain
says we could die at any moment or
descend into madness or
anything that you do could not matter
right
so that's what we're talking about is
the reversal here it's not
just a scale of values choices and
preferences it's this whole
ensemble of the the domain of what we
call the ethical
and so you say wow camus really doing
something radical here
taking that away what is what is going
on here
so a little bit later he says that
belief in the absurd
uh amounts to or is tantamount to
substituting the quantity of experiences
for the quality and
notice that there's two things going on
here
quantity versus quality which we're
going to have to clarify
and he provides us with some insight
into
but he's also talking about experiences
he's not talking about
ideals he's talking about the realm in
which we live
perceive choose the world in which we
are
agents and patients so
it's the quality the quantity of
experiences that is going to matter
he goes on and he says if i convince
myself this life has no other aspect
than that of the absurd
if i feel its whole equilibrium depends
on that perpetual opposition
between my conscious revolt and the
darkness in which it struggles
if i admit that my freedom has no
meaning except in relation to its
limited fate
then i must say that what counts is not
the best living
but the most living and notice there's
three ifs there you don't have to buy
those
camus is not saying everybody i've got a
universal ethic for you
it's going to substitute for kant's
categorical imperative
or the utilitarian's greatest happiness
principle
or pick whatever else you want the
golden rule everybody must follow this
he's just saying listen if you buy this
you buy this and you buy this if you've
been reading the book so far and
going along with it here's what i think
is the necessary conclusion
from this you need to value not the best
living
but the most living and he does have
something else
you know here that we might be a little
critical towards he says
it's not up to me to wonder if this is
vulgar or revolting elegant or
deplorable
once and for all value judgments are
discarded here in favor of factual
judgments um you know
that's a little bit dubious that we're
getting entirely away from
value and just focusing on the facts
that's a nice bit of rhetoric
but let's see where he's where he's
going with that right
he says i just have to draw the
conclusions from what i can see and to
risk nothing that is hypothetical
supposing living in this way we're not
honorable that true propriety would
command me to be
dishonorable i have to follow this out
because this
is the conclusions that follows from all
the stuff prior to
uh this in the work the understanding of
the absurd
and its you know meaning for for me as a
person
so here's where he says we we really
need to be able to
clarify this and he goes on
and says that um here we go
a man's rule of conduct his scale of
values so he's still saying that we can
have those
but they have no meaning except through
the quantity
and variety of experiences he has been
in a position to accumulate
so the the rule of conduct
the scale of values they get their
meaning
in our ongoing engagement with the world
and he describes you know the absurd uh
condition
and the world in which it's revealed is
one that's actually quite rich
there's there's a lot of possibilities
for things it doesn't mean
when we say that things are absurd that
everything is now gray and
boring and lifeless if we want to see it
that way that's that's up to us but we
don't have to
he goes on and he says the conditions of
modern life impose on the majority of
people now he's not saying this covers
everybody just the majority of people
the same quantity of experiences and and
consequently the same profound
experience and we can take into
consideration the individual's
spontaneous contribution
but i'm not going to judge of that he
says and let me repeat that my rule here
is to get along with the immediate
evidence
i see that the individual character of a
common code of ethics lies not so much
in the ideal importance of its basic
principles as like textbook authors
would say
but in the norm of an experience it's
possible
to measure and he he talks about the
differences between
cultures you know he's somebody who's
actually done a lot of study of the
ancient greeks and he talks about
you know their conception of the
their code of leisure and we have the
code of our eight-hour day
and he says already many men among the
most tragic cause
us to foresee a longer experience
changes this table of values
and here he brings up a really
interesting idea that fits in well
with our modern contemporary life
you could think of like the illusion
that's created of celebrities through
social media
and other media he says they make us
imagine that adventurer of the everyday
who through mere quantity of experiences
would break
all records and he says i'm purposely
using this sports expression in
parentheses
so he wants to use this like notion
that's pure quantity right somebody hits
more
home runs or something now they've
passed up that person's record
and it's interesting with sports fans so
many of them love statistics
and the faith that people have
in statistics as a side note is just
blindingly crazy isn't it because how
the hell do you know
that that person actually has those
numbers you're relying on
people to have accumulated these and
done the mathematics right not to lie to
you about it
you know and people will like throw
these out as if they're absolute facts
why because there is something about
quantity
that people feel is important and there
is something about like having the
highest quantity
that people think is like being a winner
being successful
until the next person passes up your
record now you're a has been right
and camus says okay i'm not really
focused on that
because breaking those kind of records
doesn't really matter
you could think about a great example of
this is
you know young young men and they're
often you know times lying about or
sometimes trying to just accumulate all
this experience
i've slept with this number of of women
right
i've got these many notches in my belt
well
that doesn't actually tell you that much
about that experience now
does it that that that accumulation of
experience
they could be you know um two-minute
shooters
they could have been entirely unaware of
what they were doing at the time
with the person who they managed to talk
into they could be lying completely
right these are illusory
experiences so simply
accumulating records that's not exactly
what kamu
means in this sense you know i also
think about
my wife recently rewatched cool hand
luke and you know the
main line from that is no man can eat 50
eggs
well as it turns out you can eat 50 eggs
it's not very good for you
is that what camus means by this when i
was i mentioned to her as well that when
i was a kid
i did something like that they would
allow us to have as many cartons of milk
as we wanted
at lunch and so on a dare a bunch of
kids said
drink as much milk as you can and i
think i got to about seven before
i got i got sick these little pints of
of milk i was like
you know 12 at the time or something no
this is not
this is not what he's talking about so
he says breaking
all the records is first and foremost
being
faced with the world as often as
possible
and he asks a question here but before
we look at that question we should think
about that
being faced with the world is the person
let's take the baseball metaphor again
is the person
who hit the most home runs did they
face the world the most some other
person might have been up at bat more
often
and they struck out you know maybe they
had like a really low
rating they perhaps in that respect of
facing the world
actually accumulated more experience so
he says how can that be done without
contradictions and without playing on
words
why is there a contradiction on the one
hand the absurd teaches that all
experiences are unimportant on the other
it urges towards the greatest quantity
of experiences there's there's a sort of
paradox here isn't there or
inconsistency but the absurd doesn't
care about being inconsistent now does
it
and you know you can get upset with the
absurdity oh you should be consistent
and the absurd doesn't care and that's
just you and the absurd relating to each
other again
so he says um how then can one fail to
do as so many of the people i was
speaking of earlier
choose the form of life that brings the
most possible of that human matter
introducing a scale of values that on
the other hand one claims to reject and
he says well the absurd
teaches us the mistake is thinking that
quantity of experiences depends
on the circumstances of our life when it
depends solely on us
now that's got to be qualified to some
degree
but it does depend on on us right
how so being or remaining
or we might say persevering in which
stresses the need to
choose over and over again conscious
he also uses the word lucidity here
at this point in the work he tells us
that
being aware of one's life one's revolt
one's freedom and to the maximum is
living
and to the maximum that is how we can
in some respect live the same life as
some other poor schmuck
but have way more quantity of experience
because we're aware of it
we don't just live in the moment and
flit from time to time and forget
everything
that would be in some respect a bad
strategy from camus point of view
we actually want to remain conscious of
the past
and even of the possibilities of the
future that is a
richer quantitatively form of
life so he says where lucidity dominates
the scale of values becomes useless
let's be
even more simple let's say that the sole
obstacle the sole deficiency to be made
good
is constituted by premature death so the
world also has a share in the
quantity of experiences he says no depth
no emotion no passion no sacrifice could
render equal in the eyes of the absurd
man
a conscious life of 40 years and a
lucidity spread over 60 years now is he
making
a distinction here between consciousness
and lucidity no this is just kamu being
a good writer
and using two words that are meaning the
same
40 years of conscious living 60 years of
conscious living
60 years has more packed in there
quantity wise
than the 40 does but somebody living 40
years of
of conscious living and 60 years of you
know just sitting in front of the tv
and chit chatting on social media and
eating the same crappy
processed food might actually have less
quantity of life in it
of experiences than 40 years of richer
experiences
right so he goes on he actually brings
up another factory says madness and
death are his irreparables why does he
bring up madness because madness can
separate ourselves
from our experience we can lose
ourselves
madness he doesn't you know define here
but you could think about all the
different ways
in which people are you know conscious
in some sense but not conscious
fully in the sense that that camus is
talking about here
and their life is over before they know
it
so madness could be clinical you know
diagnosable disorders what they used to
call back then psychosis and neuroses
or it could just be buying into
consumerism it could be buying into some
stupid political ideology
that if you really thought things
through you'd realize you've been
misusing the freedom that you have
and pissing it away on you know being
upset about this thing or taking action
on this thing right so he
he goes on and he tells us
the absurd and the extra life it
involves do not
depend on man's will but on its contrary
which
is death and he tells us the will is in
a footnote the will is only the agent
here it tends to maintain
consciousness it provides a discipline
of life and that is appreciable
so he says then we have to be able to
consent to this
there will never be any substitute for
20 years of life
and experience he does actually say
something kind of funny about the greeks
here he says
you know the greeks claimed those who
died young were beloved of the gods and
he says well that's true only if you're
willing to believe
that entering the ridiculous world of
the gods is forever
losing the purest of joys which is
feeling and feeling
on this earth the present and the
succession of presence before a
constantly
conscious soul is the ideal of the
absurd man and then he says
ideal is actually the wrong word there
right that would
put us back into like the meaning of
life he says it's not even his vocation
but merely the third
consequence of his reasoning if he
actually wants to follow through on the
realization of the absurd
and to do so in a way that's
uncompromising
and unsparing then he's going to
be stuck with it he says having started
from
anguished awareness of the inhuman the
meditation on the absurd
returns to the very heart of the
passionate flames
of human revolt a little bit later he's
going to call this
passionate understanding he actually
brings up nietzsche at the end of this
section
and says when nietzsche writes it
clearly seems the chief thing in heaven
and on earth is to obey at length and in
a single direction in the long run their
results something for which it is worth
the trouble of living on this earth
as for example virtue art music the
dance
reason the mind something that
transfigures something delicate mad or
divine
he elucidates the rule of a really
distinguished code of ethics but he also
points the way
of the absurd man
obeying the flame is both the easiest
and hardest thing to do
but it is good for a person to judge
themselves occasionally
he is alone in being able to do so and
so again
he says in this equa
equivalence encounters passionate
understanding
so do we have a full conception of what
a ethics of the of quantity
would be for kamu no he's just sketching
something out
as the consequence of what it would be
like to live without a meaning in life
and something that can be yet still
meaningful meaning producing meaning
bringing but remains radically
contingent upon
the being that we have he talks at one
point about luck
playing a role and on the world that we
are cast into that we don't choose
except in a very tiny
little portion of it that even then
resists us
so this is uh what we can call the
outlines
of an ethics of quantity
you